my guest today is paul sankey who's
known as being uh uh the analyst who
first called for oil prices to go
negative while covet began and
eventually we have the sankey research
team that he started
and uh recognized as a number one on
many different investor surveys as the
number one blog
expert that people follow in the
specific area of oil having said that
paul thank you so much for being a guest
on valuetainment
thanks for having me
the current climate so current climate
in regards to oil who is happy who is
concerned who is pushing us to get away
from oil
well listen i'm not an oil analyst
anymore right i'm a i'm an energy
transition analyst and my website
research is styled as the
uh energy transition on wall street and
you know we just had to sort of adapt to
uh to the reality around us and that's
you know the beauty of wall street we're
trying to value the future
and if you don't get that then you're
probably not going to do very well
because
essentially the value of equity is the
present value of the future free cash
flows so we're putting a value on the
future and that's our job and so if you
see an industry shifting in the way that
i did with oil
you better start shifting and by the
same token i left the bulge bracket bank
you know the watery banks in order to
start up on my own because they needed
the flexibility
uh to cover this challenge that you're
talking about
so
essentially what's happened here is that
there's been a bit of a conflation of
covid
downturn that we got as a result
basically of economic collapse
with the end of the oil age so people
have thought that you know what happened
last year which was the fed essentially
making
uh the cost of capital zero causing
renewable stocks to absolutely rip
and really causing a lot of pain to oil
stocks which were suffering from very
weak demand
you know people confused that which is
natural as a major shift that's
occurring
now in valuation terms there is a major
shift declaring because people want to
buy renewable stocks and with esg
environmental social governance there's
just no way you can make an oil stop
look good because the emissions
associated with use of oil and gas that
pipe you know it's a fact
but having said that the debate is
really shifting rapidly
and in many ways as we as we are today
which is really your question there's
actually a backlash against esg
because essentially we're facing a
global energy crisis
and so we've seen oil become the best
performing sector in the market this
year
and you know a lot of these renewable
stocks at times for example solar has
been very weak this year
uh you know i've had a much more
troubling year and there's a lot of
controversy even today
around
statements by jay powell fed chairman
about the potential for uh
for the end of the tapering and
raising interest rates because
inflation's kind of out of control our
call has been that if you think there's
going to be inflation oil prices will go
up
and you'll be long the oils additionally
the valuation of the oils will improve
relatively because if you're worried
about inflation
a stock
such as a
solar stock that's discounting 2030 or
becomes even more expensive because the
the value of the dollars in the future
will be a lot lower
and therefore what you're assuming for
their earnings in 2035 will actually be
a lot lower and therefore the stock's
very expensive and so we see that group
trading quite aggressively with whatever
the fed chairman says which is kind of
weird at the meantime the oil price is
high and the oils have better strategies
more more investor friendly and so the
group's doing very well
why are oil prices high right now
demand basically
um you know you've had a pretty
significant the first principle of
looking at oil is always what's going on
at the demand side
and the leading indicator because it's
very difficult the data is poor the
leading indicator is always refining
margins so how much your refining
companies making if the oil price is
going up and refining margins are going
negative
it tells you that it's a speculative
fear and it's not a real oil price
at the moment refining margins are going
up at the same time as oil which tells
you there's a demand-driven
uh environment and and there's a lot of
power there in terms of the demand side
additionally opec
is either both cut back production and
struggling to produce as much oil and
finally you've had capital discipline
which is a new era for the usc companies
they're not spending their returning
cash to shareholders because it's the
end of the oil age and if that's what
you want us to do that's what we're
going to do
and therefore you've also not had the
growth from the u.s that you saw over
the previous 10 years on the supply side
so essentially as you can imagine
there's a combination of supply and
demand there's controversy about how
much more of that could produce because
they're cut back
but we think that's probably not as high
as some people would imagine
and of course the other major issue is
that we're going into winter and there's
a global gas shortage which was driven
by a couple of wild card aspects one of
which was shortage of coal in china and
india
short as you call in china and india was
not on my business well it's not on my
bingo card for uh 2021 but we got that
and so you've had a huge squeeze on
natural gas which is leading to the
squeeze online so if it's the end of oil
age
uh uh
how are these big oil companies gonna
not only how they're gonna handle it are
they gonna allow that to become a
reality you're not talking about small
companies you're talking about uh a
china petroleum company
net income you know
is a 355 billion dollar company right
you got uh petrochina 320 you got a
ramco you got a shell 261 you got bp you
got exxon these are not small companies
these are guys with a lot of money with
lobbyists and a lot of people that are
making millions on top of millions of
dollars are they really going to allow
the end of oil age
you know what environmentalists miss is
that it's the companies don't have a
choice if you change your behavior so if
you buy an electric car if you start
using less energy if you put a solar
panel on your roof
if you behave more efficiently
they're powerless and that's the biggest
threat
that's my biggest frustration with the
environmental movement if they keep
attacking the supply side for example
new pipelines new pipelines are really
environmentally friendly because the
existing infrastructure is very old and
it leaks
that they oppose new pipelines because
the theory is if we stop supply
then we'll stop demand but that's
pretty regressive you know the point
being it hurts poor people more than it
hurts rich people
and you know it's pretty almost fascist
arguably to say okay i'm not gonna let
people supply energy because you
shouldn't be allowed to use it
what you should be doing is changing
your own behavior and that would then
knock the companies out where the
companies the companies are changing as
fast as they can
they've been busted in the case of exxon
for
trying to denigrate the climate change
movement which is really you know
nightmarish for exxon but most of the
other companies if you look at a chevron
or a conical phillips they just accept
that the change is happening
and they simply got to be more efficient
better players to survive
the potential for lower demand in the
future at the same time demand is not
falling demands hitting a record high
for oil and we're at 100 million barrels
a day plus which isn't it's you know 1
000 barrels a second of oil are being
used
and to replace that with with solar
people just don't understand the energy
density of oil which by the way is
naturally occurring arguably
environmentally friendly because it
comes from the earth
where you're going to be replacing it
with solar panels which are often built
90 percent more or less are built in
china using coal-fired electricity
and forced labor and you're going to
tell me that's a better option than
using texan oil so that's part of the
esg
backlash it's really dynamic though i
must say you know this is a this is an
ongoing situation fascinating to cover
obviously but
what i will say tell you is the more the
government gets involved the more
they're going to screw it up and so far
we've seen california
uk
arguably certainly germany
essentially completely screw up their
energy systems by going too far too fast
it's funny you say uk in california
because i think boris johnson said as of
2035 they're not going to allow for
gas powered cars to be sold they're
gonna ban it you can drive it but you
can't uh sell it anymore and i think
newsome announced it last week
on uh the same thing he pretty much
mimicked exactly what boris johnson said
they're gonna do it in 2035 as well so
the question it would make me think
about is paul this is your world what
percentage of oil is consumed because of
cars
what percentage is you know
can do you know the breakdown of how oil
is used around the world
sure i mean you know the single largest
sector of the oil market your market as
i mentioned is kind of elegant it's a
hundred million barrels a day a thousand
barrels a second
uh
ten million barrels a day alone is us
cars just us
so the single biggest part of the global
oil market the single biggest sector by
sector
is u.s gasoline which is used you know
really wastefully you know i think i
counted once from my son heading down
the long island expressway
we reckon that 80 of us pickups have
nothing in the back
you know why are you driving a pickup
as you know
the efficiency of the fleet here is the
same now today 20 miles per gallon as
the model t4 the model t4 was about 20
miles per gallon now of course you've
got air conditioning and dvds and what
have you but the fact is getting from a
to b
usage is very efficient overall
transport is about 40 to 50 percent
worldwide worldwide yeah about 8 million
barrels a day in aviation is very
difficult to replace
they'll tell you they're going to use
burger fat in order to make biofuel in
order to run planes but in reality you
just don't have enough burger fat
um
so there's numerous elements where you
have green washing where essentially
they say we're going to use biofront you
know renewable diesel whatever but in
fact you know the eight millimeter jet
fuel alone simply you can't run a plane
not that number of planes
uh on renewable fuel at the moment and
if you do it's going to be very
expensive and one of the key effects
will be highly inflationary food prices
because essentially what you're going to
end up doing is using soybean oil which
arguably is not that environmentally
friendly
in order to make biodiesel and so on so
the biggest marginal changes that we're
watching are basically china and india
um
in the grand scheme of things basically
about a third of oil is used in the
americas a third is used in europe in
the middle east and africa
and a third is used in asia
and the biggest marginal increase as you
can imagine is china which is now the
biggest energy consumer in the world to
the point where it's
actually um
more than europe and
the u.s combined china alone and the big
issue in energy this year actually has
been the strength of
uh chinese or electricity demand which
has been huge off the biggest base in
the world
so so paul
the key point there really is the scale
of the energy density and the amount of
energy used is very very difficult to
replace with interruptable windmills and
solar you know it just doesn't balance
you can't do it and that's what people
have to accept which is that you have to
have natural gas or nuclear
as your
transition fuels you know
so so if you're saying us out of the 10
million of the 100 million is just u.s
automobiles worldwide is 40 to 50
million aviation was 8 million what's
next so at that point we're around 48 to
58 million a day what is next what other
industry is next in oil
uh you've got the um
let me think now it basically you go
down through propane you know which is
used in home heating that's the lightest
part of the barrel then you get into jet
fuel uh and gasoline which as we
mentioned is a very large part of the
balance
and then below that you have distillate
distillate is partly used in transport
it's also used in a lot of industrial
facilities you know so you might use it
in a factory you might use it in the
generator you're gonna use it in ships
uh trains you know so that's part of the
transport balance but that's what you
would know called diesel
and then uh the remainder is going to be
stuff that you don't even know you're
using like plastics i mean one of the
key things here is that people
underestimate the importance of plastics
which you can basically either make from
natural gas or oil that's what the
global industry industry uses but that's
going to be another 10 15 20
and then finally things like asphalt you
know the heaviest part of the barrel
which obviously you use on roads
so all of that adds up to you know
an enormous number of products not just
in cars that need somehow to be replaced
and the point is really that the
replacements are not necessarily better
so what you're seeing is for example the
iea would say what you're trying to do
is shift the global economy from a
hydrocarbon economy to a mineral economy
now that might reduce your emissions but
it's going to cause a lot of problems
you know mining is not environmentally
friendly it's often done in countries
that are nightmarish like you know for
example the congo where they're going to
be using child labor to mine cobalt
et cetera et cetera and a ton of this
stuff is processed in china
you know one of the reasons i'm
independent is because i can turn around
and say look china's a totalitarian
regime
that you know you shouldn't support you
should actually oppose you should try
not to buy an iphone nobody does
and yet you'll hear yelling at me about
you know how evil exxon and chevron are
you know it's just kind of bs right
it's pretty wild what you just said
right there so you you you call china
totalitarian and they they'll stop
yeah these guys
they were just deleted if i wrote that
in my previous employers they would just
delete it they can't be rude about china
but you know i'm british my father's a
british diplomat these guys are
appalling human rights you know what are
you doing what's tesla doing should it
really be allowed to do that just today
we've had a guy from the nba putting out
what we do in tibet
and the guy's been scrubbed from the
chinese institute consulting's games are
not being shown it's like you know you
want to deal with these people and you
want to buy all your soda panels from
them he's a he's a friend in his camper
you have to scrub this webcast though
well we like webcast like this because
this gets people to think for themselves
but going back to it you said when the
government gets involved he says you
said they're indirectly not hurting the
rich they're hurting the poor can you
unpack that what do you mean by they're
hurting the poor instead of the rich
well just the energy costs a regressive
rate so that if you're a poor person you
spend more of your income on energy
and gasoline than a rich person does
it's just very regressive that's way i
got you so basic economics essentially
if gasoline price goes up it is way
worse or if the price of all goes up you
know if you know at the moment actually
for separate government reasons i think
there'll be more deaths in the uk this
winter
from energy poverty than they will from
covet we've got 40 to 60 000 deaths
coming this winter based on the gas
crisis that the government's basically
engineered
but the regressive idea yeah is simply
that you know a given person at a low
income spends far more of their income
and is far less flexible in terms of
uh you know how much they have to spend
on energy just to survive so let's say
it costs a simple example let's say it
cost two hundred dollars to reinforce an
apartment
obviously if you're making ten thousand
dollars that's a lot more
than it is if you're making a hundred
it's as simple as that
paul 40 to 50 million a day out of the
100 million is automobile okay
automobile so
actually you're making me nervous
because i did that on my head 10 million
a day for sure is the u.s
gasoline alone and then about 40
of
everything else is two
um so there's that yeah
there's somebody that really wants to
talk to you by the way i don't know
the third time they knocked on the door
you may want to just say hi to them um
but no
here's here's where i'm going with this
let's say the number is 30 let's say the
number is 40 let's say the number is 50
it's a big number so the biggest one's
going to be automobile so
i guess the question i'm asking is
if they're pushing for everything going
electric due to climate change if that
is what everybody is pushing for to go
in that direction
how are how is the oil industry these
big oil companies hedging themselves
against this
eventually going there because you're
not talking about five percent of the
business not ten percent
it's forty to fifty percent of it so how
are insurance companies how are oil
companies essentially insuring
themselves against the trend that we're
going away from oil driven cars
well basically the first thing that
happened is that people started selling
oil stocks right because they were like
we can't for example european managers
quite a few of them now have a
calculation of how carbon intense their
funds are
and so obviously if you're selling eight
million barrels a day of oil like exxon
is
you're going to basically come up with
very very high emission and therefore
you know unfriendly in terms of your
emissions and so people don't want
anyone to stop want to earn the stock so
the stock prices perform very poorly
at the point that point the strategy
began to change and so you saw some
extreme examples like vp
or total actually is a better example
because they did a good job vp did a
horrible job in my opinion would be the
total for example as of 2017 2018 said
okay look we're going to transition and
we're going to start going after
consumers
we're going to do really what i've said
you should do this address the fact that
individuals have to make an individual
decision to use less energy and be more
environmentally friendly you can't do it
any other way
greenpeace themselves would say that you
know
you're the solution you personally are
the solution you just got to ask
yourself you know how much am i flying
et cetera et cetera that's why people go
nuts when neonatal dicaprio is like
hanging out on yachts
and you know emma thompson flew from la
to join the extinction rebellion
protest in london and people were like
what are you doing you know just stupid
um so basically absolutely that the oil
companies then were forced to change and
they're really to be honest they're
really struggling with it because
the problem is that their cost of
capital is high so if the market sells
the stock their cost of capital goes up
if that makes sense to you
for example a renewables company the
market wants to invest in gives them a
very low cost of capital so they'll very
easily raise money and they can invest
and as you know the value of an equity
is the cost of cap is the returns over
the cost of capital so if you've got a
relatively low return project like a
windmill or a major wind farm that's
going to be an 8 to 10 return at best
but if your cost of capital is 2
then that's a very good return for
investors the problem for exxon is it's
yield alone it's dividend payment is six
percent
if you add that you know a cost of
capital make a return above that their
real cost cost of capital is probably 15
if we were to say something shall i
invest in a new oil project we would
want to see a 15 to 20 return
so for these oil companies
my view is they should shrink they
should just get smaller
and make very high returns and in many
ways follow the tobacco model you know
so what tobacco companies do is with a
declining market as they simply went
into a very high cash return to
shareholder mode and they became very
attractive stocks because ultimately the
market doesn't have a conscience which
is debatable now with esg the issue with
the sg is that you know is it really
morally better to use renewables than it
is oil and gas is a rising debate you
know it hasn't been one up until now but
the more people realize that solar
panels are built in china using
coal-fired power and forced labor the
more people realize that you might kill
people by not having energy available
when it's the depths of midwinter all of
these things are causing people i think
to reconsider what will be probably for
example a disastrous climate summit
coming up
here in glasgow you know in two weeks
whatever it is time november the 1st in
glasgow you have cop 26. it's probably
going to be a shambles
so all of these things are really live
debates and for the oil companies it's
very difficult because they've got the
the the challenge of maybe chasing the
ball here into an area where investment
investors don't want them to go anywhere
anyway
or do they actually just tough it out
and say you know what i'm going to stick
with what i do unapologetically in many
ways or rather i would advise them
frankly to green wash and pretend that
they're green which people are so bad at
analyzing this stuff they'll probably
buy it anyway certainly stop advertising
i don't know why they advertise nobody's
ever going to love these companies but
basically just reward your shareholders
as much as you possibly can which would
be through buyback and dividend
and keeping the lowest possible profile
is it hypocritical sure but you know
as i said if you want a friend by a
though
i'm looking at data based on what you
just said when you said tobacco and
cigarettes okay
and this data i'm looking at i can't
share it on the screen here because i'm
looking at it over here but i'll send it
to you
and it shows it shows
uh how it grew from early 1900s then
great depression increased smoking even
more world war one definitely helped it
helped it
world war ii helped it then in 1960s
the first surgeon general's report on
smoking and health came out then
fairness and doc it went from i mean you
have to see how much the numbers dropped
off it's a 50 drop off immediately
and gradually goes all the way down to
today being a quarter of what it was in
in mid 60s of smokers so a quarter of
smokers today versus what we had in the
mid 60s right do you think the trend is
going to look the same way with oil do
you think it's going to be that dramatic
of a drop off
no i mean i think you know obviously
smoking is more demonstrably directly
negative right so people make an
intelligent decision i think you know
i'm one of the few
college-educated americans that smoke
left you know you have to be really
seriously done to actually smoke
cigars in my case but you know people
still want to do it at the margin
but no it's it's going to be difficult
certainly and that's why people talk
about hydrogen because there's really no
alternate uh way of
really cold coal or cheap energy into
the heavy industry is very very
difficult to replace and again it's very
difficult to make hydrogen in an
emissions friendly way and there's no
infrastructure another point by the way
i make is if you want to recycle stuff
why would you rip up all the existing
infrastructure for oil and gas in order
to put in new that's going to be hugely
energy intensive so that doesn't make
sense to itself
but the one that is huge that we
mentioned is um
is cars you know that if you can switch
to evs now that's of course going to put
enormous pressure on on the raw
materials for evs and the electricity
system
um but ultimately that at least
massively lowers your emissions if the
electricity is made in an
emission-friendly way which really
should be nuclear
at the moment you're still 40 of us our
generation us actually thirty percent of
u.s power generation is from coal
60 to 70 of china which is really the
problem is coal
and that's going to be extremely
difficult to replace
the other issue which the child that no
one looks at which you should look at is
look at a long-term population shop you
know what's happened here is the global
population has gone to seven billion
um
on a just kind of a crazy exponential
rise nobody ever plots these emissions
on a per capita basis but the reality is
we're actually given the population
weight that we face
getting more efficient
so it's a really a major question for
the next 50 years is are we really going
to be able to replace this oil and if
you look at all the forecasts they're
just wildly optimistic it's going to be
extremely difficult and again the key
issue is environmental mechanism is a
luxury
you know it's all very well for greta to
come out and say we should use less
energy she's had a massively privileged
upbringing one of the richest countries
in the world which has had some of the
highest rates of hydrocarb production in
the world and she wants to turn around
to a bunch of indians and chinese and
say no you're not allowed to have my
life
that's kind of that's just outrageous in
my opinion greta's done a wonderful job
in raising awareness of the energy
challenge and making people think
brilliant well done to her absolutely
remarkable but at the same time her
position is so fundamentally nonsensical
when it comes to somebody who's
virtually starving in india who's
desperate not to use dung
and die of you know emphysema at an
early age because they're using dung or
firewood inside and on
this is causing debts so ultimately
environmentalism is partly a luxury and
it's partly a suicide mission you know
what you're really saying is we need
less people in the world and you're
probably going to get those people if
you really apply some of this very
aggressive and very expensive zero
mission stuff
it's a simple fact and that's that that
circle is never it's never squared if
you look at what greta said recently
she's talking about global leaders going
blah blah blah
but she didn't say she didn't present
any solutions herself you know her
taking a carbon fiber yacht across the
atlantic she said was to prove how
difficult it is which was a point well
made i mean how many people are going to
cross the atlantic in a freaking carbon
fiber yacht on top of that the guy that
drove the yacht had to fly the atlantic
to drive it you know it's just like it's
it's very very difficult and the only
thing that we can do is try and be more
efficient individually
and get governments to do a better job
of for example improving the electricity
grid or using more natural gas
so uh
to me
there is there's a few ways i see this
here so one i see
the the politics side of this
then there's the economic side of this
and then there's the guys that are just
the predictive analytics guys right
where
okay the politics is what climate change
climate change climate change
that is a number one uh uh you know uh
issue that's the number one above
everything else that we should be
worried about and so it gets when a
leader or president says that the
populists say oh my gosh climate change
the biggest issue
if climate change is the biggest issue
we have to get rid of gas we have to do
this we have to do that so it gets the
populace to say now i understand why
they want to get rid of cars okay so
that's politics but let's set
politicians aside let's set the uh
economical side aside which is guys that
are driven by profits they're like
listen if this thing drops below 65
bucks we don't make money whatever that
number is between 60 to 65 when it drops
they're not making money
my question is the data guys
and the those on the inside that are
with the with you know a government
that's sitting there like a norway
saying yeah we're just not going to get
rid of our oil right now we're going to
sit on the reserves right now we're not
going to touch it because we're going to
long our oil why are you logging your
oil so why are so many countries long on
oil
when everything about the direction
we're going with the climate change
epidemic that they're talking about
is forcing us to get away from oil if
that's really that big of an issue
why are several government handling
their oil reserves in a different way
thinking they're going to need it 1500
years from now i don't know if my
question makes any sense but
maybe it does to you based on what i'm
asking yeah my attitude is that the
first problem the most emissions
intensive is coal you know and you're
still using all-time record amounts of
coal you know and really you shouldn't
be so
coal arguably certainly the natural gas
is replaceable over time and that's 40
less emissions right there so just that
basic move you should focus on that
right but the problem is you're going to
have to change behavior in china and
india
um
as regards oil yeah it's more it's more
emissions intense and there's definitely
areas where for example in the us you
can just get much higher efficiency from
cars
and greatly lower emissions you know
and then that's even that's
controversial because where it turns
really hypocritical is sort of the
norwegians sure they don't want to not
produce their oil
but what's really hypocritical is no u.s
politician would do the most logical
thing which is just to put on a gasoline
tax or a carbon tax and force people
to pay a price for energy which is more
reflective of the emissions associated
with it
so you can't just you know run electric
heaters like crazy or drive around in a
stupid jacked up pickup truck without
paying for it you have the right to do
that but you're going to have to pay the
true environmental cost
but you know no politician because it's
widely considered to be environmental
suicide ironically thanks to jimmy
carter not environmental suicide sorry
political suicide
thanks to jimmy carter
no politician will go near ask aoc do
you support gasoline tax i'd actually
answer the question you know because the
fact of the matter is it's known that
the u.s consumer doesn't support it so
if the us consumer doesn't support it
you're kind of wasting your time in the
first place right because no politicians
no supporters then worse you have things
like the green new energy deal which is
just absolute crap i mean if you read it
it's like
running for class president saying you
know
no homework and free candy it's like
we're going to create four million jobs
from you know a whole load of wind farms
and we're going to completely take coal
out of the electricity system in the u.s
and you say well if you do that on the
time frame that you say that you're
going to do it especially given that
utilities don't want to change they're
the most boring regulated conservative
companies that have no interest in
change
it's going to be basically impossible to
do it and if you do do it the lights are
going to go out and then you're not
going to be able to use your iphone so
if you think it's going to happen the
answer is it's not it's all just noise
you know at which point you turn around
and say well look the oil stocks the oil
and gas stocks are undervalued
people might not want to own them for
more moral reasons i get it but in
reality the value of these stocks is
much higher than is currently discounted
by the market because let's face it this
oil and gas age is going to last a lot
longer than you think
so we'll see additionally we just don't
know how the environment is going to
react right because the modeling is so
poor that it's not really understood
where mankind is responsible for sort of
10 to 20 of co2 emissions and co2
encourages plant growth you know there's
a whole load of stuff that
essentially is very very unknown if you
look at the margin of error and how much
difference it makes at sea level
how much of the sea level temperature
actually changes all these things are
massively unknown so if you make
multi-trillion dollar decisions or
destroy your economy
it probably is not going to make a whole
lot of difference quite frankly
depressingly enough so i think what
we're going to do is basically live
through a long emergency here
unfortunately and you should plan
accordingly i live in brooklyn heights
you know for a good reason you don't
want to be at sea level too much not so
much that it'll be flooded but that it's
going to flood a lot you know throughout
the year it's not going to be underwater
but you'll see a lot of volatile weather
it's tough i mean it's it's tough and
frankly i think the politicians are
doing a horrible job
we'll see
so so so then if that's what you're
saying let me kind of restate what i
think you said is
so is this all just a bunch of show
is this all a show what they're talking
about in regards to oil knowing this
thing's not going to be going away
somewhat yeah i mean i think the
clearest thinker in my mind in one is is
not fashionable to say to say the least
but if you listen to vladimir putin who
explains you he'll say to you look
he said this at the russian energy week
this past week electricity doesn't come
from a socket you know what i mean
you've got to generate it
what you really need is
for one year to have a dictator come in
and say look this is actually what needs
to be done and everybody do what i say
we're going to build nuclear we're going
to plant trees we're going to upgrade
the grid
we're going to use natural gas to offset
interruptability of wind and solar and
we're going to max out wind and solar
but we're not going to buy it from china
if they use coal-fired power or forced
labor to make it it's not complicated
what's actually happening is you know a
whole lot of nonsense about union jobs
and you know president biden's saying
we're going to take carbon out of the
electricity system by 2025. you're like
well he means 2035 and by the way that's
bs so it's double bs you know what i
mean it's just like what are these
people talking about aoc is clearly very
intelligent very brilliant politician
she doesn't know jack about energy
people just don't know the units they
just don't realize how much 100 million
barrels a day is in solar panels if you
want one gas station
made by solar power you need to cover
the whole
the whole of manhattan needs to be a
solar pump and then you'll get one gas
station's worth of gasoline when it's
sunny so i mean you know the idea that
we can replace oil and gas with sodium
and by the way these guys like apple and
google yeah they're still renewable yeah
all that data centers are located in
coal heavy cheap electricity zones
and what they say is we now covered all
our electricity usage from renewable
energy
but we know that renewable energy
doesn't run at night and we know that
women doesn't blow when there's no wind
yet somehow the data centers run 24 7.
it's just just just a lie they're
they're more guilty in many ways than
exxon and chevron who basically pretty
openly admit that they produce oil and
gas and it's not going to be that great
for the environment
paul what's the what's the what's the
right thing to do if if if an
administration said listen we want to
bring you in we want your inside we want
you to help us
think long-term what's the right thing
to do what would be the right thing to
do right now
they should all read fact smell or
somebody who's good on energy who
explains to you energy density and you
know who can put everything in terms of
horsepower he can do it in any unit you
want the thing that people don't
understand is units they don't
understand how much electricity they use
how it's made
and you know
the fact that it's 30 made by coal in
the us so that every american uses 20
barrels of oil per head per year
even the most efficient tree hugging
green is going to be using 10 which is
five times the per capita used in china
which by the way has multiplied by five
times over the past ten years that is to
say the average chinese uses five times
more role than they did and which
there's still
only twenty 20 of what the average
american
uh uses you know and so all this stuff
about hey i'm environmentally friendly
it's just like you're really not you
know and by the way what happens if i
take plastics out of your life because
people don't even think about that they
realize that hey i used a paper straw
it's like come on man get real you know
look at where your uh your
pharmaceuticals have delivered from it's
basically partly from an oil company you
know it's it's really really tough and
it's being driven by
partly alarmism partly genuine concern
but above all it's in a political
environment where it's so difficult in
democracies to make real massive change
right because it's a democracy so right
now we have 50 50 in the senate and joe
manchin is like i don't want to lose
coal that's the end of the u.s energy
policy for four years basically
he's uh he's uh the most
respected and hated politician right now
from uh opposing sides some like him
some hate him
uh interesting when we realized it would
be a 50-50 senate and joe manchin was
head of the energy committee it was like
yeah i don't think much is going to
happen here but um
he's right in one regard which is you
know
you printed 20 of all the dollars ever
printed last year right
and now you're saying we're gonna do and
by the way the recession is the shortest
in history and we're long since out of
recession because they printed so many
dollars and somehow they're like okay
let's print another 1.2 or 1.2 for
infrastructure and why don't we throw in
3.5 for
for a human infrastructure which you
know you just read through it and you're
like this is just absolutely insane i've
been to visit a friend in washington
outside washington you should see the
mansions
that are being built on the outskirts of
washington as you go down
uh you know into some of the greener
areas down there literally it's new
mansion being built new mansion being
built you mentioned being built because
you know all these washington dc guys
are making insane amounts of money from
insane money printing that joe manchin
is saying is insane
paul why are you so diplomatic
i'm being sarcastic yeah
mansion after mansion i'm looking at an
article here
with uh newsom
because he's trying to pass gas taxes
says california california expands road
mileage tax pilot program so rather than
increasing gas he wants to track how
many miles you're driving
to tax you based on the miles you're
putting in rather than taxing your
gas the direction he wants to go in
california this is a pew
trust article
yeah i mean that also would take into
account obviously road you know having
to maintain roads because the other cost
of uh
there's two additional costs to to you
know heavy use of cars one is obviously
you've got to maintain the roads the
other is arguably that you go and fight
wars in iraq right so i mean
i i actually testified to the senate and
they begged me not to and i said well
why not it's a fact that if you wanted
to pay for the war in iraq through a
gasoline tax you should add i think at
the time it was 2.50 to every gallon of
gas sold in the u.s
that's how much the war cost don't tell
me it wasn't about oil
so you know they were not happy about
that but you know it's like yeah you
shouldn't be
paul how often are you in uh
south florida
about once a year for vacation
that's about it got it okay well if
you're ever down here i'd love to have
you on the podcast to
go along from two to three hours because
uh
i love the way you think i love the
answers i love the insight it's very
helpful but i've really enjoyed this
conversation with you man you're not
only
smart interesting and you got a great
sense of humor
appreciate it mate thanks a lot i'd be
happy to come see you around miami beach
that's where i go
i mean i'm a forta del boca so if you're
ever out here would love to host you and
we'd love to have you on the podcast
yeah there's some money there as you
know there's uh there's a couple of big
fund managers so i'll be down there
sometime in the next year fantastic
looking forward to it thanks for being a
guest buddy really enjoyed it
take care bye-bye
crazy how a paul sankey ended up being
one of my favorite interviews of the
year i hope you enjoyed it as much as i
did if you did give it a thumbs up
subscribe to the channel and i did a
video on uh uh that you may or may not
like it was predicting the fact that i
think gas prices are going to get to 10
a gallon here very soon matter of fact a
county in central coast a city in
central coast gas station prices were at
7 58 just this week if you've not seen
this video click on this video take care
everybody bye-bye
you